j'étais étonné de recevoir un le
scénario d'appel de rennes de ce que je
t'aime les données qu'ils sachent qu'ils
étaient
et dans ces moments là j'avais beaucoup
de d'admiration et de respect pour lui
en tout cas que ce noël je sens que
c'était quelqu'un qui avait un débat
artistique qui dépasse juste l'image
vous pouvez en faire un acteur qui joue
hors des films j'ai entendu sa musique
et dans ces cas-là on espère que
certains le viper cours parce que si
c'est pas bien ça c'est encombrant et
j'ai adoré scénario j'ai adoré l'idée
d'un pneu noir qui s'inscrivent en rien
et il n'y avait pas beaucoup de lignes
de dialogues mais je savais que il donne
sa chance à chaque personnage donc après
le plus long ça a été faire le visa